So after nominating Amy CONI Barrett to replace
Ruth Bader Ginsburg on the Supreme Court,
Donald Trump had another one of these rallies.
And you can tell he's emboldened, he's feeling
powerful, he's feeling the alpha male, although
remember that we can still hold him accountable
for his perversion of democracy and remove
him.
Let's look at a few clips from this event.
This was a rally in Middletown, Pennsylvania.
It was truly horrifying.
Yes.
Donald Trump was again struggling to speak,
of course, will get those out of the way first
saying Joe Biden should be asking people not
for forgiveness, but for for give TIV Nesson.
All right.
Take a listen to this.
You shouldn't be asking for your vote.
He should be begging for your forgiveness.
Oh, yeah.
That's not really the dystopian part.
It got truly dystopian and authoritarian.
Very, very quickly, Donald Trump here commending
U.S. Marshals for killing a man who was suspected
of murder in Portland.
One eyewitness says that the man was executed
by U.S. marshals.
Note that this doesn't include this thing.
What's that thing called?
The right always talks about it.
Oh, due process.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, due process.
It doesn't include due process.
Take a look.
Portland is an Oregon, and you had the guy
two weeks.
You'll remember he shot and killed a young
man in the middle of the street.
Just shot him like, oh, I don't even say like
what?
Because his parents are so devastated.
A young man and they shot him and killed him.
This one guy was one animal and two and a
half.
That's right over his head.
Not our hand is another.
It was a Christian and it was a Christian
that he was a Christian.
He was a Christian.
And they shot him, killed him instantly.
And this guy that shot him, everybody knew
he was right.
And I said, after two days, he.
Did you arrest him?
No, he didn't.
After two and a half days, did you arrest
him?
And then I put out on social media.
Why didn't you arrest him?
And you know what the U.S. marshal saw?
They went in and he pulled a gun on him.
And 15 minutes it was all over.
None of our guys were.
These crowds will cheer for anything.
They they truly will.
Then Trump continuing with his fear mongering
about the election thanks to mail in ballots,
which Trump is simultaneously saying will
be fraudulent.
But at the state level, the Trump campaign
is telling people their supporters request
absentee ballots.
Vote by mail, vote by mail.
Notice in this one that Donald Trump's fear
mongering starts to peter out like he almost
it looks like he's running out of batteries
and he seems to realize he's not making much
sense.
So he goes back to the teleprompter, which
he uses despite attacking Joe Biden for using
one.
It's actually jarring when Trump switches
from riffing aimlessly back to the prompter.
And all I'm asking is people go out to vote,
go out to vote and stop with this nonsense
because we're going to be counting ballots
for the next two years.
And I don't want to end up in the Supreme
Court and I don't want to go back to Congress,
even though we have an advantage if we go
back to Congress as everyone understands it.
I think it's twenty six to twenty two or something
because it's counted one vote for state.
So we actually have an advantage.
So they're going to be thrilled that I'm sure
they're trying to figure out how can we break
that one.
Biden wants to confiscate your guns and indoctrinate
your children with poisonous anti American
lives in schools.
Donald Trump does this unintentionally hilarious
thing during these speeches where he reads
the teleprompter, not as if they're his own
words.
He reads the teleprompter as if it's a news
article that he's commenting on and then he'll
react to it.
Sometimes he actually seems surprised by what's
on the teleprompter.
Very, very odd, particularly for a guy who
criticizes everybody else for using teleprompters.
Then his fans start chanting, lock her up
when Hillary Clinton's name was raised and
Donald Trump says, I agree, lock her up.
That was like Hillary.
Remember, she made a horrible statement about
clean coal and then she went crooked Hillary.
And then she went three weeks later.
I agree.
Trump has now said, really, everybody should
be locked up.
Hillary should be locked up.
Obama and Biden at one point he said 50 years
in prison, they should be serving for their
crimes against Trump.
Trump still has not enumerated what those
crimes are, but for their crimes against Trump.
I believe James Comey should be locked up.
It actually sounds like a dictator when you
say anybody who disagrees with you politically
should be locked up.
Trump then still having trouble with the size
of his crowds.
Trump claims there were 35000 people at his
rally the previous night in Virginia.
There were reports there were reportedly 4000
people there.
Take a look.
If tens of thousands.
Somebody said 17, 18000.
Last night we had 35000 people in Virginia.
You know, we're making a play for Virginia
because we have a governor in Virginia.
You know, the facts simply do not matter.
The facts don't matter about the micro.
The facts don't matter about the macro.
It is a culture of lies.
It is a culture that does not care what reality
is.
Coronavirus.
He did great.
We're doing great.
Well, that's a lie.
Crowd size is some pathetic rally you shouldn't
even be having.
He says 35000.
It was really 4000 maybe.
Then Trump starts talking.
This is almost sad.
If this weren't the president, it would almost
make you kind of feel pity. Trump is talking
about his Nobel Prizes as if he won them as
opposed to being nominated for them by bogus
right wing European politicians.
Take a look at.
But the fake news never even put it on.
And somebody had a show where they said the
amount of time devoted to Donald Trump's.
Nobel Peace Prize.
Two of them, zero on the network, zero.
Then the amount of time devoted to something
else that was negative for somebody in the
Republican Party like Infinite.
It is so disgraceful.
They are so bad.
Trump's two Nobel Peace Prize is why he has
no Nobel Peace Prizes, as you might know.
And then Trump starts to wrap up his speech.
But he kind of gets sidetracked riffing about
how he has all of these weapons at his disposal,
the likes of which no country has seen before.
And he, again, seems to still think that a
stealth plane is not just invisible to radar.
He still seems to think it's invisible to
the naked eye.
And he pulls out that sir routine that we've
come to know so well, Mike.
And we will ensure peace through strength.
You know, we rebuild our military.
You saw 2.5 trillion dollars.
We have weapons.
The I mean, just to talk about them, the likes
of which no country has ever seen before,
the power, the strength, the the incredible
talent and engineering.
We have weps, weapons, the likes of which
no country has ever seen before.
We are so far advanced over every other country
and hope to God we never have to use them.
And when I got here, we were depleted, tired
military with great people.
But we were exhausted.
We had old jet fighters.
Now we have brand new F-35 that is stealth.
I asked one of the pilots, how good are these
planes compared to the enemy?
I said, well, one difference is you can't
see our planes.
I said, Let me ask you.
I don't know too much about flying.
That helps, does it?
You said it really upset me.
So you can tell you can tell that, yes, the
rallies have always been whacked.
They've always been gong shows.
But you see an emboldened Trump on the basis
of having nominated a replacement for Ruth
Bader Ginsburg and the probably accurate assessment
in his defense that he is likely to get her
confirmed.
We've got an uphill battle ahead of us here,
my friends.